nueva zelanda es un extraordinario país
de poco más de 4 millones y medio de
habitantes y una superficie de 268 mil
kilómetros cuadrados algo menos que la
de japón o la de italia situado en el
pacífico sur se puede decir que nueva
zelanda está literalmente lejos de todo
y es que aunque viendo el mapa tengamos
la sensación de que está junto a
australia les separan en el mejor de los
casos algo más de 1600 kilómetros
gracias a ello podemos encontrar
especies endémicas tan simpáticas como
el kiwi un ave nocturna que no vuela y
que es el auténtico símbolo nacional
a pesar de ser un país tan aislado nueva
zelanda ha conseguido convertirse con un
modelo único en uno de los países con
mayor nivel de vida del mundo en este
primer vídeo sobre la tierra de los
kiwis te contamos alguna de las claves
más llamativas de su éxito
si alguna vez estado allí sabréis que
podemos considerar a nueva zelanda como
la tierra de la alegría la simpatía y la
calidad de vida os aseguro por
experiencia propia que no exagero
hablamos de una tierra de acogida donde
uno de cada cuatro habitantes ha nacido
en el extranjero y donde incluso la
lengua de signos tiene el rango de
lengua oficial y lo cierto es que sus
ciudadanos tienen muchos motivos para
estar más que contentos y satisfechos no
a zelanda
eso de los cinco países más seguros del
mundo su economía es la tercera más
libre de todo el planeta y según el
ranking doing bussiness es el segundo
país donde más fácil es hacer negocios
además por si fuera poco es considerado
como el cuarto país menos corrupto del
mundo hay más empleo que en la media de
los países de la ocde y cuenta con
sistemas educativos sanitarios y
culturales excelentes es decir nueva
zelanda es a todas luces un éxito
económico social y de integración pero
dejando hasta un lado en este vídeo nos
vamos a centrar en una de las claves de
su éxito que a la postre uno de sus
rasgos más característicos el campo
nueva zelanda tierra de agricultores y
ganaderos
nueva zelanda es el único país
desarrollado donde el sector primario ha
ganado peso en las últimas tres décadas
representando hoy casi el 7 por ciento
de su economía de forma directa por
comparar cabe destacar que en el caso de
la unión europea el peso del sector
primario es del 16 por ciento del pib
cuatro veces menos que en nueva zelanda
incluso un poco más del 2 por ciento de
una potencia agrícola como es españa se
antoja ridículo al lado de nueva zelanda
no hay un caso equivalente en todo el
mundo
por ejemplo la leche y los productos
lácteos son la mayor exportación de
nueva zelanda y sumando sus diferentes
conceptos el sector primario y la
industria alimentaria representan casi
el 60% de todas las exportaciones
comerciales del país podrías imaginar
que el campo fuese los dos motores
principales de uno de los países con
mayor bienestar y nivel de vida del
mundo
la competitividad del campo netherland
es es tal que además la consiguen sin
subvenciones de por medio por ejemplo
cada año la unión europea reparte
subvenciones a los agricultores y
ganaderos por un importe que equivale a
cerca del 20 por ciento del valor de su
producción
tan sólo en españa- la unión europea
tiene previsto desembolsar entre 2014 y
2020 la friolera de 47 mil millones de
euros en ayudas al campo en nueva
zelanda en cambio las villas se quedan
en el 0,7 por ciento de los valor de
producción 27 veces menos que en la
unión europea y el gasto está enfocado
sobre todo a investigación e innovación
el ahorro es como vemos sustancial
el roger no mix y la revolución agrícola
en el flandes
ahora bien esta situación no fue siempre
así a principios de los años 80 cerca
del 40% de los ingresos de las
explotaciones agrícolas y ganaderas de
nueva zelanda correspondían a
subvenciones del gobierno por aquel
entonces la economía no hace la cndh esa
era un ejemplo de proteccionismo y como
consecuencia de ello atravesaba una dura
crisis el déficit público era enorme
casi el 10 por ciento del pib bien
inflación de dos dígitos la deuda
exterior no paraba de crecer el
desempleo aumentaba y la economía estaba
estancada
ya ha pasado un mes porque no crece ni
algo en este contexto en 1984 el
ministro de economía del recién elegido
gobierno laborista
roger daghlas impulsó un ambicioso
paquete de reformas conocido como roger
no mix que liberalizaba muchos ámbitos
de la economía y que el sector primario
pasaba por eliminar los controles de
precios y suprimir la mayoría de los
subsidios ayudas públicas al campo
además para combatir la inflación el
gobierno subió los tipos de interés lo
que condujo a ganaderos y agricultores
que habían subido muchas deudas en los
años precedentes a la tormenta perfecta'
más gastos en intereses de la duda y un
desplome en el valor de la tierra así
que ya os podéis imaginar que la
transición no fue del todo
y así me gusta que convierte la
agricultura pero pronto aparece unos
beneficios que conllevaban poner fin a
las subvenciones la pérdida de ingresos
estímulo a los agricultores a buscar
innovaciones que incrementasen el valor
de la producción introduciendo nuevos
cultivos mejorando la calidad y
apostando por métodos más ecológicos al
tiempo que controlaban estrictamente los
costes ya no se trataba de maximizar la
producción de los frutos subvencionados
sino de mejorar la cadena de valor
orientadas a los consumidores y reducir
costes por ejemplo la subvención de los
fertilizantes se había traducido en un
uso indiscriminado de los mismos
aquí es donde empaquetamos sabe y los
hilos lo que hacemos es que las galletas
tengan tengan un maravilloso aroma o un
aroma natural y fresco comprende y se
consigue con un pulverizador químico
cuando la subvención terminó el consumo
de fertilizantes se desplomó sin que
haya afectas a la producción los
granjeros aprendieron a utilizarlos sólo
en casos necesarios lo que además de
reducir los costes de producción tuvo un
efecto muy positivo sobre el medio
ambiente lo mismo ocurrió con todos los
inputs respecto a los nuevos cultivos y
productos podemos destacar el
impresionante desarrollo que ha tenido
por ejemplo la industria
donde la superficie de viñedos se ha
prácticamente triplicado en la última
década y sus vinos se han convertido ya
en una referencia mundial asimismo con
el objetivo de encontrar nuevas fuentes
de ingresos la población del santo no
rurales comenzó a desarrollar negocios
complementarios como es el caso del
turismo rural y los productos
agroalimentarios elaborados en ambos
casos muy dependientes de la
conservación del entorno y la
construcción de una marca bien valorada
y de esta forma los propios agricultores
y ganaderos comenzaron a preocuparse por
la protección del medio ambiente
el resultado fue impresionante al final
sólo 800 explotaciones el 1% fueron
liquidadas en los 20 años posteriores a
1986 la producción del sector creció un
40% desde que se eliminaron los
subsidios el sector creció más que la
economía en general y entre 1986 y 2006
tuvo un crecimiento sostenido del 5,9
por ciento anual casi nada también fue
relevante la apuesta por la
internacionalización que ha conducido a
que hoy el campeón holandés exporte
competitivamente más del 90 por ciento a
su producción y encima han mejorado
también
nueva zelanda es un ejemplo de cómo las
convenciones y las malas políticas dañan
la innovación la diversificación y la
productividad al tiempo que por supuesto
se convierten en un lastre para las
cuentas públicas así es el caso de la
pac la proteccionista política grande de
la unión europea que nos cuesta a los
miembros de la unión y la acción edad de
50 mil millones cada año hemos acordado
que 150 millones es una ofensa no
aceptamos menos de 150 mil millones
frente a ello nueva zelanda nos muestra
quién haciendo bien las cosas podemos
ahorrar mucho dinero al tiempo que
mejoramos la situación de las áreas
rurales los neozelandeses han derribado
al mito de que la agricultura no puede
prosperar sin subvenciones para
revolverse españa imagínate el narón
potencial que pueden tener regiones como
cantabria asturias galicia o extremadura
los ganaderos alertan de que el sector
primario de cantabria se va a la ruina y
desde luego los gobiernos
latinoamericanos también deberán tomar
nota y apostar por la capitalización del
campo y es que mientras en nueva zelanda
tienen como objetivo duplicar sus
explotaciones agrícolas para 2025 aquí
seguimos pensando prácticamente sólo en
repartir más y más subvenciones qué
pensáis vosotros creéis que sin ayudas
el campo se moriría es posible replicar
el éxito de nueva zelanda espero que os
haya gustado este vídeo si ha sido así
dale a like y suscribirse al canal si
aún una vez hecho ya un saludo y hasta
el próximo vídeo